you actually ended up on our radio show
doing a Nutrisystem a commercial kind I
did not knowing who on earth you were I
know and you know was not a career move
like I'm gonna go because they were like
well first yeah you you you say they say
would you like to go in the Howard Stern
Show and I'm like who's Howard Stern
radio show like well I've never been on
the radio that'll be fun wasn't so much
fun was it well I just remember what
exactly what I was wearing I was wearing
white Reebok high tops with punchy white
socks and a pair of khaki shorts and a
tank top and as I walked in I just
remember hearing jungle cries Oh jungle
cries jungles I guess it was cuz it was
had a Safari vibe to what I was wearing
the only thing I remember about that was
I remember everyone thought you were
incredibly hot that was number one and
number two I remember Gary bababooey a
lot of it
he decided he has said this all these
years like oh you know I could have
gotten Jennifer Aniston before she was
famous because she wanted me that day
and I said you got a [ __ ] kidding me
she wanted you I don't that's his story
he thinks you know something far back
that is part of your appeal this is what
I always say every guy thinks
that like Jennifer Aniston would be into
it because you come off like you're not
too you know full of yourself that's
part of your appeal but you're here to
say you are full of yourself and every
guy can get you know we're interested in
Mary